we've made a lot more just besides these
and maybe one day maybe one day I'll
talk to you about my feature-length film
the woods that I made while as I believe
16 I want to say 16 that one was 84
minutes long and maybe when I hit a
million did not hit her it's not true
it's bullshit I did not hit her I did
not oh hi mark
party anything
[Music]
ah this is gonna be fun oh man so as
many of you know I started making films
when I was about 14 years old and
throughout most of my teenage years and
then to adulthood I continued to do it
today I still make movies now and it's
definitely my passion and I promised you
guys back in the day that when I hit a
million subscribers I would review my
second feature length movie believe it
or not I actually made one before this
it was a baseball film that I made when
I was about 14 into into 15 I think with
my friends it stars two of my friends
who have been really clear about the
fact that they don't want their image
shown in videos ever so to respect them
I won't but this is actually my second
feature like movie the first one was a
baseball movie when I was about 15 and
it was about 70 minutes long so it
counts its feature length oh this one
took two years to make I would say I
started writing it when I was about 15
and it took two trips to the state of
Pennsylvania because we filmed a lot of
it at a cabin in Cook Forest
Pennsylvania one camera one tripod and
about 1 billion mosquito bites at this
point we had to made a lot of short
movies that were just really silly and
really fun but we had never tried
anything to this level and we worked
extremely hard on it my friends and I
all had normal jobs at this point I
believe I was working at Taco Bell at
the time and my other friends had jobs
and so we all had schools still a few
more years of school and so on the
weekends or when we had free time during
the week we would try to film this movie
and we were able to film about half of
it in Pennsylvania at this cabin where
the main character lives and for the
rest of the movie wherever there was a
scene that was in the woods we could
film that in Ohio so it took us two
years to make and I think I started
writing as I said around age 15 and
probably finished around 17 or 18
because we didn't start filming till I
was about 16 so you can see me ever so
slightly age during this movie if you if
you knew me well enough at the time you
could tell that I had slightly aged
through out the process of making this
movie so the film is
about a guy named Mark Smith great name
I know and he is blind he's been blind
for about two months but the film opens
with a guy named Stephen Scott played by
my friend and he has just seen something
he's very disturbed he's not sure what
he just saw and he feels the need to run
in to his house grab a notepad and
immediately draw it down you don't know
why he's drawing it down but it's
clearly a UFO even though it kind of
looks like a chocolate-chip cookie
he's very scared about whatever he just
saw and he wants to draw it down we
learned more about that later but then
he hears a sound like something entering
the atmosphere in the sky above him and
he goes to look at what it is and a
light fills the area
[Music]
so that was our big intro it's sort of
supposed to be like who like what the
fuck just happened you know like what
does that mean and you learn more about
it later I got to say before I get in
this like this movie technically is
fairly awful the cinematography is all
handheld except for what tripod shots we
had which are a lot which we'll get into
later why there's so many tripod shots
the sound is all camera audio really bad
there's no lighting at all you would
call this guerilla style filmmaking if I
was trying to sound like a pretentious
a-hole the truth is we just didn't work
hard enough and didn't have the money or
the ability to have all that equipment
but we seriously worked our asses off on
this movie and I got to give it to a lot
of my friends because obviously I wasn't
paying them this is all just for fun and
for a while it turned into work real
work I mean two years on a film that's
ended up being about 84 minutes long
that's work so we're introduced to Mark
Smith who's sitting in his favorite spot
by the river he has a chair there and
for about two months now he's been
getting used to the area he's trying to
make like a mental roadmap of where
everything is so that he can walk around
without having to use his walking stick
too much which by the way yes is a
broomstick and since again we were so
fucking cheap
I had to write in a joke later in the
film which we'll talk about about why my
Chi uses a broomstick so he gets up from
the chair and he walks away and for a
second he thinks he hears something and
he stops and he turns around
[Music]
that moment comes to play later in our
film and we'll talk about that when we
get more towards the end of the movie
now we see the cabin that he lives at
which was actually a cabin that some
friends of my owned and they let friends
and family rent it out for vacations so
since I was about 16 when we started I
didn't have my license yet
so my parents and I went on two trips we
took us two times to film at this cabin
the first trip my parents went with me
and they entertained me you know they
let me do everything for every single
scene that has me in that house my
parents were either out or they were
sleeping like in the next room and I had
to do all my lines and everything with
my parents in the very next room hearing
everything it was so embarrassing
but I got it done that's like it's AG we
finished it so the same light that came
out of the sky and abducted the guy in
the first scene now comes to my cabin
except instead of abducting me it kind
of blasts my guy to the ground and you
feel pressure forced into the room and
since he's blind
I had to sell somehow that he could
sense that something was wrong so he
touches his face like he feels a burning
sensation of some kind because he can't
see obviously and so he's like oh I feel
like my face is burning like that lights
so hot and then he's very confused by it
obviously and has no idea what just
happened so we cut to 24 hours later we
get our first insert shot of this
cloaked being that's standing outside of
the cabin we find out that mark has just
called the sheriff who's played by my
dad and since we of course had no
sheriff uniform we have like this stupid
joke
sorry I'm not my uniform but I was at
home when you called hey Chris at age 16
that still doesn't make any sense
sheriff's and pops they have their
uniforms at home just so you know Chris
cheese so the sheriff checks out the
house there's nothing strange mark is
very confused because he knows he felt
this sensation on his face and it kind
of blew him to the ground like the
pressure came in and just kind of forced
him to the ground and so he knows
something is wrong but he doesn't know
what it is so we cut to later in the
night
so now with nighttime and something is
happening outside there's something
trying to get in it's circling the house
and obviously mark is very scared by
this one of the things about this movie
is since it was just my parents and I at
the cabin and I couldn't have any of my
friends come with me the first time or
the second time pretty much every shot
inside the cabin had to be a tripod shot
that was set up by me and then I walk in
front of the shot and do what I have to
do so there's so many tripod shots and
all of the cabin stuff and I mean I
tried to have as many angle changes as I
could for something like this
[Laughter]
so the next morning mark is very
concerned he doesn't know what those
sounds were he's wondering if someone's
stalking him or if it was just somebody
playing a prank he runs outside really
quick drops the trash in front of his
driveway and runs back inside and we get
our first little look at this cloaked
thing
so later that night my mom introduces a
news report local residents Steven Scott
was recently interviewed about a strange
occurrence that happened to him this is
what he told us
thanks for doing that mom I needed a
news lady voice and you helped me out in
a bind so Steven Scott is the guy from
the opening scene and it's revealed that
he went through some sort of abduction
process that's what he thinks anyway
he's on the news talking about it
he lives local elections guys is called
entire area and is talking about thanks
if you like it is burning it's not like
there's fire in your life but I knew
there wasn't just intense why darling
can I say I knew I was staying with
accurate the strange thing was
I had no resolution of the day employed
from the light his muscle and he is
saying that he has no memory of the past
few days that all he can remember is
seeing that light that that is just
burned into his memory and beyond that
he's lost all of his memory of the past
few days so mark is like okay that
sounds kind of like what happened to me
because he described a burning sensation
and he felt the burning sensation so he
instantly wants to see being connect
with this guy to see if maybe they have
some sort of weird connection so he
calls the sheriff and he agrees that
tomorrow he'll take him over to Stephen
Scott's house because the sheriff in
this movie is kind of like Mark's helper
he like has taken it upon himself to
assist mark and all of his issues
because he knows mark lives in the
middle of nowhere so for the second
night in a row this stalker being of
some sort tries to break in and attack
mark for whatever reason this thing
doesn't just grab a rock and break one
of the windows and come in he just wants
to scare mark a lot I guess this is
where the movie starts to get really
plot holy because there are so many
things that we'll discuss later where I
look back on how I wrote it when I was
like 15 and I'm like dude you didn't see
all of these plot holes like I don't
know we it's just it was like we were so
passionate about making it and
especially myself I was just so into the
idea of making it I didn't care so much
about the hardships or the flaws I just
really wanted to make it and that's kind
of how a lot of us felt back then I've
talked about this sometimes in the past
on my videos we had a lot of blind
inspiration where we would just come up
with an idea and we just instantly was
like let's just film it obviously with
this movie we planned it a lot more but
in the end we just wanted to finish it
and now all these years later I can look
back and be like yeah mmm no not so much
we'll talk more about that stuff later
some market grabs a knife and
investigates the sounds and here's some
strange other-worldly growling and this
is the first hint that mark gets that
it's not just a person that it might be
some sort of monster so the next day the
sheriff who by the way still hasn't
found that uniform of his drops marked
off at Steven's house and mark is able
to chat with Stephen about their similar
experiences so you're lying huh how'd
you figure that out so walking sticks a
dead giveaway
lots of room stick it's cheaper ah like
I said we we really didn't have much of
a budget so we did we worked with what
we had so the two of these guys talked
and as I said Stephen remembers the
light that he saw that caused him to be
abducted but he has no other memory of
anything but he has the drawing that he
made
I don't remember drawing this I can't
remember a thing about this drawing
but this is what really got me the
bottom right-hand corner of the page
there's a date written in my handwriting
523 2005 US House just a few days ago
that's the day I can't remember that's
the day I saw the light
so that is making him think that he was
abducted by aliens and this is something
that he's very passionate about like he
believes it it he believes in all that
conspiracy stuff my guy mark it's like
hey like I remember everything I just
there was like a burning sensation and
stuff and my memories still intact and I
don't believe in aliens you know my guys
like like the Scully like if he's the
molder I'm the Scully I'm the skeptic
you know so this movie takes place in
the year 2005 don't ask me why I set it
there I don't know why but it takes
place in the year 2005 and this is the
date that he wrote down on the drawing
and he's like that's the day I can't
remember you know that's when I saw that
light and so my guy is like instantly
thinking you know there's a connection
here there's something I think I saw
something was George down in this
notebook so I would never forget it
because the news they're going to try to
take it away from you someday
so they both realize that they share
some sort of connection but mark it's
like you're full of shit basically and
leave so the next day mark is back at
his favorite spot by the river and he's
basically thinking about the past few
days and what could possibly be the
answer to this weird scenario he's in
and the creature once again stalks him
and he gets really scared and runs away
another humongous plot hole I have with
this movie is how in the world in just
two months this guy has conditioned
himself so well to surroundings to be
able to maneuver himself as well as he
does through things well being blind
also if I'm like sixteen or seventeen
even if I'm like 18 in this movie how am
i living alone like in a cabin in the
middle of the woods with no family
nothing it's so dumb oh my god so later
the sheriff comes back to Mark's house
and warns him that there's been
sightings of this cloaked figure and he
wants to make sure he's aware of it
because other people have reported it
and Mark is like thinking I want to go
back to Steven's house I feel like
there's something else we didn't talk
about and the sheriff agrees to take him
there because mark really doesn't have
any idea what the hell he's doing
at all in this movie we're going to get
a DES later
Mark's a horrible fucking character he's
a terrible protagonist he is so dull so
the next scene all these years later is
probably my favorite scene in the movie
it's like a 10 to 12 minutes sequence
it's
where the movie changes and shifts from
being sort of like this
suspenseful investigatory thing it's a
more of like a suspenseful adventure
like thing and I don't know
basically the sheriff takes mark to
Stevens house for a second time and
there's a really good idea here that I
still actually really like and that's
mark enters the house he knocks on the
door and he's trying to find Steve and
he gets worried because no one answers
and he walks inside the house he of
course shouldn't really be there but he
watch inside the house anyway and we the
audience see that the house is trashed
it's totally totally trashed but mark
can't because he's blind so he just
proceeds inside like nothing's wrong I
like that idea because I like the idea
of the audience being one step ahead of
the main character for just this
sequence anyway it makes you feel a
little more scared for the character
probably like the one idea all these
years later in this movie that I think
still works okay so mark investigates
the house and check out my friend's
old-ass TV and Sponge Bob poster that's
what I'm talking about
that's production value
so mark goes near the basement and he
doesn't want to go down there because
for whatever reason he senses that
there's just something bad there like it
just the idea of going down there scares
him so he decides to go in the backyard
instead plus he's blind so like I don't
really blame him he goes in the backyard
and he finds something interesting
so Steven is dead he's been killed mark
goes and finds the sheriff and the
sheriff investigates as well who also
does not feel like going in the basement
the sheriff finds the dead body and they
both leave and now we get to see what
was in the basement
[Music]
[Laughter]
so in the quickest most absurd character
change of all time
mark decides he needs answers he
absolutely needs the truth he has no
idea what's happening and he wants to go
find the truth and he's positive that to
do so he has to go confront whatever
this thing is and he thinks it's in the
woods he thinks it's beyond the open
meadow boundary that's outside of his
house which he after that he has no idea
what's beyond that meadow outside my
cabin there is a small section of woods
and after that there is a small open
meadow and then another section of woods
begins and I have no idea where it ends
this was just an excuse for me to have
the rest of the movie be in the woods
and have a lot of suspenseful scenes in
the woods we tried to sell the idea that
mark is like tortured by the fact that
he doesn't know what's going on and he
wants to have answers about why Steven
is dead and where this light comes from
and what it is but it just it's not
clear enough in the movie this character
choices it's just so quick and abrupt
and obviously a choice made to just have
a lot of suspenseful scenes in the woods
and I was looking for a place that had a
big open meadow and then a line of trees
and I remember I was driving with my
parents in Pennsylvania and I was like
stop stop stop and they're like whoa and
I was like just stop right here and we
found this place and I was able to film
there it's so overblown I had no idea
what ISO was or white balance or
anything
[Music]
oh my god he entered the woods like I
said all the wood sequences I was able
to film at home in Ohio which meant I
could get one of my friends to help me
with the camera so we actually have some
movement once you get into the woods
strangely enough it actually does help
the movie that the first half is almost
entirely tripod and the second half has
like actual movement it makes it feel
like a different movie which was kind of
my goal it's one of the few ideas that
actually worked out in the end so for
Mark's first night alone in the woods I
wanted him to get no sleep so we
basically spent the entire night hearing
strange forest noises while filming this
I was directly outside my old apartment
I used to live out when I was a teenager
in timber top apartments in Ohio if any
of my subscribers live in timber top
first off I'm sorry that place is not
the greatest place we did not enjoy
living there after a while so many
apartment buildings burnt down there
tons of college parties speaking of
college parties well filming this
sequence for the entire scene I had to
take out all sound because somebody was
like playing this absurdly loud Basie
rap music and so I had to like Foley
every single sound in this scene
[Music]
mark is really a terrible character he's
kind of a dumbass he took no food no
water nothing just a knife that's it and
he's blind my guy is so dumb in this
movie it is such a poorly written
character I have no excuse so the next
morning mark finds what he's looking for
[Music]
the creature chases him and he loses his
walking stick and his knife and during
this scene you can see just one of my
countless bug bites that I got while
making this movie so after my guy
escapes the creature which is strange
because he was actually going out there
to find the creature but he's also
running from the creature like you think
it would just be like hey give me
answers I really need to know shit I'm
blind and I don't know how different
mark comes across an area with a lot of
ledges and cliffs we filmed this at
Virginia Kendall in Ohio we also filmed
one of my Indiana Jones movies there and
for this scene we actually got to film
inside a cave that's now completely
closed off to the public you can't go in
there now but while we were filming the
scene we were allowed to so we got to
have like this cool cave in the movie
mark is in this cave and he starts to
feel like maybe the creature is in there
so he runs away and sure enough the
creature is there and this is where the
movie just the plot holes just start to
crush it it's like he's out there to
confront this thing because it's been
stalking him and he's pretty positive it
killed that guy Stephen and now that
it's there he's fleeing from it and it's
like dude what is your goal here man
like and aren't you kind of thirsty
[Music]
the next scene is easily my least
favorite scene in our film I borderline
hate it mark is just sitting there and
the Sun is going down as one cool shot
of a sunset and that's about it he's
talking about how he started to think
about the only thing he wants to do when
he gets home if he gets home is sit down
at this table and have a drink that's
all I can think about and that's
basically the main thing I was trying to
convey in this scene because it comes
into play later but it's so boring it's
so ham-fisted it's so like not subtle at
all it's awful next I found a place to
insert some animal shots that I got
because Ed timber top we had this
balcony and I was able to get some
pretty good close-ups of this squirrel
and then there was some deer that came
close to us while we were filming and I
decided to incorporate them into the
film as well because you know production
value so this day mark decides you know
what I fucked up I need to find my way
home he has lost his way entirely though
but he knows that when he left he was
going south so he has to find the
northern direction and to do so he looks
for moss growing on the north side of
trees and starts to follow it beyond a
lot of things that I learned well
filming this movie about how to make
better movies I learned that I'm immune
to poison ivy because there's a shot in
this movie of me straight up sitting in
it and I didn't get poison ivy I've
never had poison ivy in my life and I
made a feature-length movie in the woods
so now we're getting close to like the
big scene where Mark starts to connect
the dots about certain things
and this is where we learned this thing
is most certainly a creature it's an
alien it has weird creature II arms and
a it drools a lot like the xenomorph and
you can clearly tell where I was
inspired to do that and we just had like
a really shitty mask that's all we had
we didn't have any moving parts or jaws
or anything so I could really only show
it a couple times because if I showed it
too much it would become really obvious
that it was fake and we did our best to
kind of make it seem like it was cool
but in the end we could only show it in
certain angles and share certain ways it
kind of paid off in a way because a lot
of people I showed it to back in the day
they were like I was always really
curious about what was under that cloak
but once you actually do see the thing
you're like that's it so this is where
Mark starts to realize things he begins
to think about the things that happened
to him in the past
Stephon talks about how the only thing
he could remember was that light that
came out of the sky because it was just
so incredible that it's stuck in his
memory and he said it was the most
amazing thing he had ever seen and for
whatever reason when Steven was abducted
his memory was erased and he's positive
that they were erasing his memory of him
having seen the UFO that passed overhead
they were trying to keep that knowledge
out of the public Mark is like oh wait a
second I remember that time in the
beginning of this movie where I was
sitting by the river and I heard a sound
and now I show you what happened
with the rest of that scene because in
the beginning I have him just stop and
turn around and you don't know what that
was now I'll show you the rest of what
happened
[Music]
so in the very beginning of the film the
UFO the same one that passed overhead
Steven and abducted him pass overhead
mark and Mark saw it so when he goes
back to his cabin the UFO comes back and
tries to abduct mark to erase his memory
but it can't because mark is blind and
the way you get abducted is when you see
the light that's like the big twist so
Steven got abducted because he's not
blind but Mark didn't so they send this
alien down to earth to essentially kill
me because they're trying to wipe out
all knowledge of aliens on earth by
anyone who ever accidentally sees one of
their ships they don't want to be known
why are they on earth I guess to study
us or whatever and the whole idea of
like getting sucked up once you connect
like visually with the light is kind of
stupid too but it's the big twist of the
movie I don't know I thought it would be
so epic when I wrote it when I was
fifteen and then I was like I saw it I
was like yeah it's kind of unclear and
everyone I showed the movie to I had to
explain it to no one got it instantly oh
man we did our best so the creature
finally attempts an attack which is so
stupid another major plot hole if it was
sent down to earth to kill me because
they couldn't abduct me why didn't it
just break it in my house like for real
just like bust through the window or
something no and all this time it's just
been creeping around it's never finally
it tries to attack me and I remember
that earlier in the film I kind of
encountered this protruding branch and I
somehow find my way back to that and the
creature gets impaled on it village the
village sorry a little bit of costume so
the creature gets impaled mark is so
really if he walks off now it's very
clear that the major inspirations with
this movie was signs the village and
alien most certainly those three the
village because main characters blind
cloaked a monster signed because of the
suspense and everything an alien because
there's an alien and it was very obvious
in this predator as well in this movie
also the like the creepy forest stuff
it's clear where all the inspirations
combined
to become like this movie so after
following the northern direction mark
comes across the river and his chair
that he knows his favorite spot he
realizes he's close to home and he's so
relieved
the creature is still alive it's not
dead yet that's definitely the moment
that startled people the most when I
showed it to them and I was always like
waiting like to see if anyone jumped
like it's the one moment in the movie
that's kind of like a drum scare moment
but it's not false like it actually is
the creature and now the creature comes
after mark full-blown wants to kill him
he's got mark it in like a headlock and
everything and there's all this alien
type imagery and you see the thing space
bully for the first time and Mark is
like you don't have to kill me I didn't
see your ship I don't know anything but
before anything can happen the creature
dies of its wounds markets like super
relieved and he continues towards this
cabin and he finds home and he's so
happy he sits down and he has his drink
at the table like he wanted to this
whole time and the film ends with mark
sitting in his favorite spot and
strangely leaving his walking stick
behind and that really confused everyone
I showed it to they're like wait is he
not blind anymore like what would happen
like it's ambiguous I'm 17 years old I
so hard with this movie and we had a
great time making it but essentially
it's supposed to be like a metaphor for
Mark is free now he has freedom he
doesn't need this walking stick he has
survived being in the woods lost and now
he's able to you know walk around
without it which is so stupid because
anybody who actually is afflicted with
blindness will tell you that even if you
know everything about your surrounding
areas there could always be like
something that you don't see that it's
in your way you have to have your
walking still get to just ending but I
thought it would be kind of cool to talk
to my friend who plays Stephen Scott in
this movie a little bit about our
experience with this film so here's a
little bit of that discussion
the most serious contribution I think
you ever gave to any two films we ever
made was probably the woods yeah do you
recall the what I do I do you have any
fond memories of the woods you can share
with us oh just pretty much being in the
woods I really like I really like
major and I really just like oh my god I
like all the trees yeah that's really I
think I saw something once and I drew it
down in this notebook so I would never
forget it because I knew they're gonna
try to take it away from me from that
it's like they think me in my brains
like they think they can control our
thoughts like this in person sort of
experience the funny thing about the
woods is that you know I was taking all
these directions for me I had no idea
what the movie was about because I was
like kept super secret under wraps and
like you wouldn't tell me a thing about
it
and I actually didn't see it for like
about a decade later right in the end I
could not be happier that we made this
movie it took us a long time there was a
lot of arguments and squabbling amongst
friends it was legitimate work I mean
especially for my friend who played the
creature in all honesty it was like 80
to 90 degrees and he was wearing that
rubber mask rubber gloves and a wool
cloak and his clothes I mean he
definitely deserves a lot of thanks for
that and of course my friends who helped
me with the camera my parents were going
to Pennsylvania everyone was always
trying to help create this and it was it
was so much fun honestly as a team to be
working on this even though it didn't
really turn out that well for us at the
time we were all really happy with it
and I still am because it taught us how
to budget a film properly it taught us
that we should probably hire
professionals quite often especially
myself I was like yeah acting in movies
probably not my forte definitely like
directing overacting we learned so much
about camerawork and cinematography on
this movie and we just had a blast doing
it and I wanted to share that with you
guys because I promised I would when I
had a million and it helps you
understand a little more I talked about
this in my reviews of my Indiana Jones
movies but it helps you guys see that I
know how hard it is to actually make a
movie and that's I think super important
for any film critic or movie reviewer is
to have really tried in the past to have
made one because it gives you more of a
respect level for Phil
Maker's and it's easier to understand
how difficult it is to balance a real
production when you've tried when you
have had like no money which was pretty
much us at that time I mean I worked at
a fast food place my other friend was a
custodian he still is a custodian
actually and so we all were just trying
to create something while also balancing
our everyday lives
and at the same time it was super
eye-opening for me to understand how
hard it really is to make a movie and I
think a lot of people who review films
can benefit from having try that all
these years later I love watching it and
making fun of it it's hilariously bad in
so many ways but it reminds me to be
passionate about what I love it
continues to remind me to just try and
work and if you have ideas just do it
man you know I'm so glad we finished
this movie if we hadn't finished it I
would always look at that and be like
I'm Alisha I had just tried an extra
couple months it but we finished it and
so we can be proud of that thanks so
much for watching this guys I have no
real other major productions from my
young years really beyond the ones I've
shown you there's a ton of random crappy
short films but the Indiana Jones movies
and this one and then I told you have a
feature-length baseball movie but I
can't really show any of that because
the main stars of it are they don't want
their image shown online so but thank
you so much for for enjoying this
hopefully with me I had a lot of fun
talking about it with you guys and thank
you for subscribing to my channel it's
really truly heartwarming to be able to
discuss film with so many of you I am
truly honored thank you very much as
always and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]